alors je m'appelle laurence colin comme
vous avez pu le comprendre je j'ai
grandi et je suis en 67 donc j'ai fait
mai 68 forcément j'ai grandi dans les
cévennes avec à côté d'une maman un
petit peu hippie dans une grande maison
il y avait une grande table avec une
cuisine arabo y avait toujours un petit
plat qui mijotait ma maison est à trois
kilomètres de mon école donc quand je
sortais de l'école le jeu c'était
d'attendre ma maman au bistrot du coin
bistrot du coin dans les cévennes c'est
pas n'importe quoi parce que les pistons
sncd réseau bassanne culturel et si une
mixité à l'intérieur de chaque bistrot
en tous les cas il ya bien une ligne
éditoriale et bistrots les chasseurs
c'est pas du tout bistrot des notables
et bistrots des intellos c'est pas le
bistrot des chasseurs donc dans ce bar
j'attendais ma maman est pas possible de
travailler pas possible de faire mes
devoirs impossible de lire
donc j'ai pris goût à écouter les
conversations des grands et à les
observer
quand maman arrivé en général on est une
famille de bavards c'était reparti et ma
mère arrivée à la conversation
beaucoup avaient rarement on avait quand
même un petit peu fin de conte disais à
ma mère bon tu veux pas qu'on embarque
tout le monde à la maison ça va être
plus simple on va continuer la
conversation autour de la grande table
et que petit plaque avait mijoté tout
l'après midi
donc voilà comment j'ai retrouvé à ma
maison souvent le notable le gendarme un
punk de baba cool échoué souvent un
passant qui ressemble souvent à benjamin
ma mère avec chic pour les trouver et
les accueillir à la maison et tout le
monde se refuser le monde jusqu'à pas
d'heure et moi j'étais petit je me suis
toujours dit c'est bizarre ces gens donc
quand je les croise dans la rue ils ont
vraiment l'air différent cliquant
l'aimer tous autour d'une table d'un
lieu commun et que on a un bel art de la
conversation qui a partagé
bizarrement ces gens leurs différences
ont transcendé et finalement ces gens
sont reliés
donc ça c'est une des premières choses
qui m'a beaucoup intrigué et j'ai trouvé
que s'il y avait une certaine magie je
parle vraiment de magie des liens quant
à mon père mon père il évoque alors un
broc
c'est pas du tout un antiquaire un
antiquaire savant un objet rare un broc
savant un objet en
wable alors un vrai que c'est un
personnage ça de la gouaille un cigare
des costards au velours en général ça
vous prend de haut et puis quand ils
voient qu'un passant a regardé avec une
petite lueur dans l'oeil à l'objet
introuvable qu'il propose
le broc là il commence à dérouler son
scénario quand un broc des roues déroule
son scénario vous avez deux choix
possibles
ça veut continuer de passer soit tant
pis pour vous vous allez rentrer dans le
scénario et vous allez devenir acteur
vous êtes venir acteurs de quoi vous
allez devenir acteur de l'histoire de
l'objet comme dirait mon père s'est
jamais vendu une armoire mais j'ai
toujours vendu de l'histoire des
armoires donc souvent si le scénario
tient debout et que ce jeu d'acteur vous
plaît pas vous reportez avec cet objet
et puis l'histoire qui avait commencé
avant vous continuez avec vous plus tard
quand j'ai fait mes études j'ai eu du
mal à trouver un endroit où on puisse
réunir tous ces trucs magiques
alors j'ai part choisi j'ai appris à la
fois les sciences politique l'économie
le droit mais aussi l'esthétique les
scénarios les pontes la mythologie et de
ce parcours transversale mais venu une
question pourquoi forcément segmenter
les gens et sk pas moyen de relier tout
le monde avec des choses qui nous
transcende
malgré nos différences de goûts
socioculturel et donc j'ai travaillé
cette question et il me semblait
également que si on arrive à résoudre
cette équation
on pourrait peut-être pérenniser des
modèles économiques ou dynamique qui qui
qui au lieu de nous segmenté d'aline
relier alors il se trouve que dans ma
vie en fait je sais pas j'ai toujours
été dans des lancements de projets c'est
ma spécialité
quand ils réussissent je sais pas je
m'envole je m'étiole mais quand il faut
les lancer je suis souvent là et il se
trouve que j'ai lancé particulièrement
des artistes alors quand j'ai commencé à
lancer des artistes ont nés en 98
internet c'est un peu les balbutiements
par contre ce que j'ai remarqué c'est
que quand on joue devant un public
un artiste quand il a un public naissant
il ya une centaine de personnes
composaient des amis la famille des
cherry les anciens cheryl
au chili le futur chéri bon voilà ça
c'est public d'un groupe qui démarre et
puis maintenant grâce à facebook on sait
que derrière une seule personne
il ya un potentiel de 200 à 500 amis
donc ça veut dire que le groupe qui joue
dans un bar devant 100 personnes s'il
s'est engagée ces personnes dans un
scénario où il devient acteur
en fait ils jouent devant déjà bercy
donc moi j'ai eu la chance de travailler
qu'artiste pauvre il n'y avait pas de
budget dont j'étais obligé d'être
créative et comme n'y avait pas de
budget mais il y avait toute cette
intelligence collective devant moi qui
était composé de ces 100 personnes avec
un coefficient de 200 à 500 les
embarquer dans mon aventure
et donc j'ai fait un marketing que
j'appellerais collectif et je me suis
basé sur en fait les micros médias
sociaux que nous sommes tous puisque à
partir du moment où on donne du sens et
l'envié du désir aux gens ben en fait
ils sont ils se transforment eux mêmes
en micro médias sociaux et avec ça donc
enfin pour privilégier ce ça en fait il
a fallu des outils de conversation et il
se trouve qu'avec internet c'était
beaucoup plus facile mais nous sommes
pas encore à l'ère d'internet
mais vous verrez qu'on voit déjà la même
définition c'est à dire que nous sommes
déjà à notre échelle des interactions
des interactions sociales les
conversations c'est déjà de la création
de contenu et un public c'est déjà de
l'intelligence collective très
dernièrement
ah pardon je reviens sa conversation
alors la conversation c'est important
parce qu'en fait c'est quelque chose
qu'on a un tout petit peu négligé en
mendiant en s'attardant sur la
communication qui est aussi une très
belle très belle chose mais la
conversation c'est un art noble alors la
cour martiale sous scellés dans les
salons ses aînés dans les centres salon
a une dans une petite période de temps
où il y avait plus trop la guerre
c'était une période
cool au xviie siècle c'était vraiment
très court je précise et en fait c'est
un art qui a été codé par les femmes et
qui a été pensé dès le début comme le
contraire d'un nerf de la guerre
la conversation s'est d'abord basé sur
l' écoute bien sûr
et sur le plaisir et le plaisir et la
recherche d'une belle formule donc ça
sous-entend une ligne éditoriale ça
sous-entend de réfléchir comment on veut
s'exprimer et dans quel sens on veut
donner et quels sont les les outils
sémantiques qu'on veut partager comme
dit madame de staël c'est déjà une forme
de sociabilité et la sociabilité ça veut
dire ensemble ça veut dire collectif
très dernièrement je rencontre un
artiste et on se pose la question se
pose la question
pardon qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
d'intelligent de pertinent et d'original
sur ou avec les médias sociaux
cet artiste c'est matthieu chedid cm et
donc on est moi il m'a semblé que déjà
sur les médias sociaux il me semble que
c'est déjà un devoir de ne pas
abandonner votre audience votre public
aux médias sociaux
certes c'est là où vous allez commencer
à converser avec eux mais vous allez
vous donner de la peine à avoir une
communauté de 50 mille cent mille deux
cent mille trois cent mille hellal
gorath l'algorithme de facebook va
décider que vous parlez à 10% 20% ou 30%
de votre communauté pourtant c'est bien
vous tout seul qui paye et le community
manager c'est bien vous tout seul qui
fait des stratégies pour réunir ce
public autour de vous
donc pourquoi laisser la date allait
donner à facebook
donc moi j'ai construit un site avec
mathieu que j'ai souhaité un site média
donc avec du contenu et du sens à partir
au moment où on commence à dire qu'on
fait un site média le problème c'est que
ce soit vous êtes riche et vous pouvez
produire des contenus
soit vous avez du temps et vous pouvez
là on s'est dit dès le début mathieu
disait qu' il avait vraiment envie que
ce soit un site dédié à son public
donc je lui dis pas dans ce cas là on va
aller produire avec eux et donc la seule
chose qu'on a à faire c'est en fait
construire un scénario dans lequel les
gens ou arrêtez d'être des passants et
sont devenus des acteurs
donc on a organisé des rubriques qui
sont autant de salons de conversation et
il ya aussi également des comment
persuader des sujets fin des comment
dire des petites des petites quand je
peux dire des petits sujets en fait que
les gens proposent donc la communauté
pardon il ya un jeune qui a 15 ans qui
propose des cours de guitare il ya
quelqu'un d'autre qui écrit tous les
mois donc en fait on à sourcer auprès de
notre communauté toutes les envies et
tous les délires il ya juste une ligne
éditoriale qui marche sur des mots clés
à partir du moment où vous rentrez dans
ces mots clés vous pouvez participer au
délire collectif
il se trouve que ce site en fait il est
déjà mondiale on l'a pas encore lancée
mais il ya déjà une communauté de 2000
personnes et il ya déjà des bolides une
bolivienne qui parle avec une américaine
qui parle avec une française et le
souhait depuis le début de manager cette
communauté dans une vision collective et
pas uniquement collaborative et
participative mais de relier tous ces
gens entrent en dans les mots clés qu'on
a données emails mot poésie
il y avait les mots bienveillants donc à
partir du moment où on a proposé juste
quelque chose aussi dérisoires que
poésie et bienveillance les gens
commençaient à se relier et le site
il a déjà que de moi et les gens
commencent déjà à parler de se
rencontrer
si vous allez sur le site vous verrez
que vous pouvez jouer et pour une fois
la géolocalisation sert justement comme
sujet la rencontre c'est à dire que bien
sûr on s'est rencontré dans un salon de
conversations virtuelles mais on peut se
rencontrer dans la vie et continuer le
délire dans la vie pourquoi pas faire
des projets on peut jouer de la musique
on peut faire des clips on peut faire
plein de choses que de façon
collaborative sur ce site et on peut
rencontrer des gens avec qui on peut
faire ces choses collaborative parce que
parlant quand on peut aussi faire un
clip on peut proposer son propre clip de
matthieu chedid donc voilà ce qu'on peut
faire avec des artistes mais forcément
je me suis une fois que j'ai terminé ça
que j'ai vu quand deux mois alors
comment dire la puissance que ça
commençait à prendre puisque en fait
voilà le schéma à quoi correspond ce que
l'on trouve de façon habituelle dans l'
approche communicationnelle une entité
avec son public
et voilà ce qu'on peut trouver sur le
site de matthieu chedid la question que
je me pose pourquoi par exemple la
culture où tout ce que le patrimoine
tout ce qu'il ya quand même une portée
symbolique et du sens pourquoi ils
utilisent encore ce mode de
communication avec leur public alors que
celui ci me semble
totalement crucial à notre époque les
gens ne demandent que ça d'être lié les
gens ne demandent que ça de données on
le voit depuis tout à l'heure avec tous
les gens qui interviennent donc est-ce
que c'est pas à la culture et est
comment dire et aux artistes de
commencer à relier une communauté
ensemble j'ai imaginé nous sommes à
bordeaux le monde du vin est ce qu'il
pourrait pas y avoir sur la cité du vin
vous fera peut-être un peu corriger la
loi evin mais ça on va s'en occuper plus
tard est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas faire
des salons de conversation où chacun
pourrait parler de son émotion lors
d'une dégustation
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas parler il ya
je suis sûr qu'à des gens qui
connaissent la vie des châteaux qui
connaissent des anecdotes à partager qui
enrichirait le propos qu'aucun
communiqué nous donnera à partager ça
valorise les gens ils sont utiles ça
leur fait plaisir on rentre dans un
rapport de reprise réciprocité et donc
on passe du pouvoir dominant qui est
souvent figé à la puissance de la
multitude et ont créé une dynamique
je pense que par exemple pour reparler
du vin je pense que ça permettrait aux
vins de rayonner d'une autre matière
manière que n'importe quelle campagne de
presse ou même de télé c'est pas mal
comme ça
alors mon marketing du coup j'ai trouvé
qu'il était à la base conversationnel
mais qu'à l'arrivée il est politique
pourquoi parce qu en fait au lieu de
diviser en marché il relie les gens et
donc il est politique parce que il nous
empêche de rester en mode individuel
comme on nous le propose à longueur de
marketing et de communication et nous
propose de rentrer dans une approche
plus collective ce qui est quand même
assez paradoxal pour un mot que ça fait
du marketing et qu'on n'attend pas
vraiment là donc voilà je vous laisse
méditer là dessus et au plaisir de
continuer la conversation avec vous